getreu dem lemotto Mission vorwärts
schaut das Bundesheer in die Zukunft und
achtet dabei natürlich auch auf die
Nachhaltigkeit wir schauen uns gemeinsam
an wo im Bundesheer das PFC Siegel mit
Projekten und Produkten aus nachhaltiger
Waldwirtschaft vorkommt das Bundesheer
verwaltet etwa 10 000 Hektar Waldfläche
so wie hier am Truppenübungsplatz in
allensteig und bewirtschaftet diese nach
PFC Standards diese Form der
Bewirtschaftung ist uns ein besonderes
Anliegen weil wir selbst Produkte aus
nachhaltiger Waldwirtschaft herstellen
und nutzen so z.B hier im
heresdruckzentrum unserer PFC
zertifizierten Druckerei mit rund 40
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern hier
werden Broschüren Folder Plakate und
andere Druckprodukte hergestellt so wie
unsere Sonderausgabe ein her voller
Möglichkeiten das hier produziert wurde
und mit dem PC Siegel ausgestattet ist
damit nutzen wir die wichtig Ressource
Holz aus garantiert nachhaltiger
Waldwirtschaft und Holz ist auch ein
wichtiger Baustoff in unseren Kasernen
so wie hier hinter mir das
Unterkunftsgebäude in der
vondergröbenkaserne in Feldbach ist ein
jüngst fertiggestellter holzmodulbau das
nachhaltige und neuwertige Objekt bietet
210 Soldatinnen und Soldaten Unterkunft
und ist ein Muster für weitere
holzbauprojekte auch in der Beschaffung
achten wir auf Produkte aus nachhaltiger
Waldwirtschaft wie z.B beim Papier
wir verwenden wo wir nur können Produkte
mit PFC Siegel der Klimawandel der geht
uns alle an als österreichisches
Bundesheer leisten wir einen aktiven
Beitrag indem wir Papier und Holz aus
nachhaltige Waldbewirtschaftung nutzen
und das zeigen wir auch mit dem PFC
Siegel auf all unseren Druckwerken des
heres
Druckzentrums